zusammen und herzlich willkommen an den
empfangsgeräten zu zdf heute live heute
mit einer diskussion um die aktuellen
corona maßnahmen denn da wird ja heftig
gestritten über das beherbergungs verbot
für reisende aus risikogebieten in
deutschland über sperrstunden über
alkoholverbote übermaßen pflichten an
öffentlichen plätzen aber auch über die
quarantäne pflicht für reiserückkehrer
oder über so sachen wie die frage sollte
man oberflächen jetzt es infizieren oder
ist das ganze übertriebene vorsicht da
wird zwischen bund und ländern heftig
gestritten
da wird zwischen den einzelnen
bundesländern sehr munter diskutiert
jetzt schon seit mehreren tagen die
erste mission dort außerdem noch mit und
natürlich die betroffenen wie die
gastronomen die gastwirte und auch die
hotelverbände die sich alle natürlich
irgendwie davon betroffen sehen und eine
meinung haben
wir wollen uns diese ganzen umstrittenen
maßnahmen fünf an der zahl haben uns
ausgesucht mal genauer angucken heute
abend und mit dem hamburger virologe
jonas schmidt-chanasit darüber sprechen
eure fragen kommentare wie immer gerne
in die dafür vorgesehenen spalten oder
an zdf heute - live chat zdf.de ich
werde gucken was ich da mit rein nehmen
kann und da ist er auch schon in berlin
zugeschaltet
hallo schön guten abend herr schmidt
chanasit schönen guten abend nach mainz
blicken sie eigentlich noch durch bei
diesen ganzen verschiedenen regelungen
die wir in den letzten tagen und wochen
bekommen haben ja ich blicke noch sehr
gut durch weil ich mich eben sozusagen
auf die regeln besinne die wirklich sinn
machen die die grundlage für unseren
erfolg sind und das ist also abstand
hygiene alltags masten und lüften und
ich denke mit den regeln kommt man noch
weiter gut durch die pandemie und was
man jetzt eben machen muss es einfach
diese regeln auch konsequent durchsetzen
weil das ist das problem in den letzten
wochen und monaten gewesen dass ich eben
mehr und mehr mitbürger nicht so
konsequent an diese regeln gehalten
haben und dadurch haben wir jetzt dieses
problem so und da ist die politik
gegangen hat versucht neue maßnahmen
neue regeln zu finden die sie
durchsetzen möchte die umstrittenste
davon derzeit heiß diskutiert ist das
beherbergungs verbot für reisende aus
innerdeutschen risikogebieten eigentlich
hieß es da ja am anfang macht urlaub in
deutschland dass es sicherer und jetzt
ist es auf einmal gar nicht mehr so
beifall als risikogebiet zählt jetzt ein
kreis in deutschland in dem nur kurz
ablesen weil es sind auch viele zahlen
50 neuinfektionen pro 100000 einwohner
im sieben tage schnitt aufgetreten sind
ist so richtig herr schmidt chanasit
oder das ist so korrekt wie habt ihr
schon daran sehen sie dass das relativ
schwer ist weil diese zahl kann ja
unterschiedliche ursachen haben
das kann einen sehr konzentrierten
ausbruch geben zum beispiel wie beim
tennis oder das kann ein geschehen in
der fläche seien also schon die ursache
für diese erhöhte zahl kann ganz
unterschiedlich sein und führt auch zu
unterschiedlichen bewertungen insofern
ist hier wirklich die frage bei einem
sehr dynamischen geschehen ob diese ob
dieses beherbergungs verbot letztendlich
realistisch ist ob es durchsetzbar ist
meines erachtens nicht und chinesisch
nicht vorweg wir möchten noch mal ganz
kurz gucken wo es überall diese
risikogebiete gibt herr schmidt chanasit
ich zähle mal kurz auf berlin bremen
köln das halbe ruhrgebiet ist betroffen
frankfurt am main
hier bei uns um die ecke mainz ist auch
betroffen münchen stuttgart also viele
große städte insgesamt 13 millionen
menschen und die dürfen jetzt eigentlich
gar nicht mehr verreisen
ja so ist es eigentlich ist es wenn man
das konsequent jetzt wirklich
durchsetzen reiseverbot weil die test
strategie ansicht die man ja sozusagen
anwenden könnte um dann in diese gebiete
zu gehen ist auch nicht sehr zielführend
ich mein sollen jetzt 13 millionen
menschen die arztpraxen und die
testzentren stürmen das ist ja absurd
die ressourcen wäre neben für andere
menschen benötigt diese wirklich
dringend benötigen also erkrankte vor
allen dingen natürlich also hier stellt
sich die frage der verhältnismäßigkeit
und ob diese maßnahmen zielgerichtet ist
und sie wird sich einfach in dem maß
auch gar nicht umsetzen lassen wer soll
das alles kontrollieren das ist ja die
zweite frage
sie gucken es gab noch mal anna schmidt
chanasit wir haben einen ganz kleinen
einspieler vorbereitet wer in einem
innerdeutschen risikogebiet lebt und
verreisen will bekommt unter umständen
gar kein hotelzimmer
aktuell gilt ein beherbergungs verbot in
zwölf bundesländern
es sei denn gäste bringen einen
negativen corinna test mit höchstens 48
stunden alt die meinungen dazu sehr
unterschiedlich beherbergungs verbote
zum beispiel zwischen berlin und
brandenburg machen doch gar keinen sinn
wir haben hunderttausende pendler jeden
tag die begegnen sich im einzelhandel im
nahverkehr auf der arbeit und dann darf
ein berliner aber zwei tage nicht im
spreewald übernachten
das macht alles keinen sinn will auch
nicht verschweigen dass das thema schon
auch ein sensibles ist wenn wir haben
vollkommen unterschiedliche
infektionsgeschehen und dass ich ein
land wie schleswig-holstein was im
moment bei 8,5 als richtwert nicht
gedanken macht was ist eigentlich mit
ländern die im moment insgesamt über die
schwelle rübergehen finde ich ist auch
etwas absolut verständlich ist
verständlich vielleicht aber bringt es
auch was unmöglich zu sagen wie sich
dieses bewerbungs verbot tatsächlich
dann auch das infektionsgeschehen
auswirkt das lässt sich dann in der
regel ist monat hinterher sagen so
soweit der sprecher des
bundesministeriums für gesundheit herr
schmidt chanasit virologe die
zugeschaltet in berlin hätten man nicht
eigentlich jetzt schon zeit genug gehabt
zu testen ob solche beherbergungs
verbote vielleicht sinn machen oder so
kommt jetzt diese abwartende haltung des
gesundheitsministeriums her relativ
schweren pandemie aber nochmal das
problem entsteht nicht durch das reisen
sondern was man macht wenn man verreist
ist also die reiseart das spiel sowohl
im inland als natürlich auch bei den
auslandsreisen eine rolle
und hier geht es einzugreifen und das
kann man natürlich im inland viel besser
machen die man eben bestimmte
veranstaltungen eben reduziert und dazu
gehören nun mal die großen
veranstaltungen mit hunderten von
teilnehmern die unreguliert irgendwo
stattfinden die reise an sich ist doch
nicht gefährlich das leuchtet doch jedem
ein wenn ich mich alleine ins auto setzt
der kreis als fahrer und zwei wochen im
ferienhaus verbringen das ist doch
absurd und ich glaube das leuchtet jedem
ein und wie gesagt gerade nochmal diese
zusätzliche test belastung jetzt
stattfinden könnte wenn sich eben alle
die reisen wollen auch testen lassen
das führt das ganze nochmal auf eine
spitze eben der absurdität
das heißt sie würden nicht die reisen
untersagen und das auf und den
aufenthalt untersagen sondern die art
und weise wie man an orten zusammen
kommt stärker regulieren ja natürlich
wir wissen doch wo die infektion
aufgetreten ist und warum soll man etwas
dagegen machen wenn
hotel ein hervorragendes hygiene konzept
hat was auch umgesetzt wird wo sich alle
leute dran halten oder ein restaurant wo
das hygiene konzept umgesetzt wird dort
ist doch kein risiko dort entsteht kein
risiko insofern noch mal es geht weniger
darum dass irgendwer wohin reißt sondern
was dort an den orten passiert natürlich
sollte keine hochzeit mit 600 leuten in
kiel stattfinden von neukölln an die aus
berlin gekommen sind das leuchtet hier
mal da haben sie gerade schon ein
stichwort gegeben hotels gaststätten die
man sich dort verhält ist eine frage da
gibt es die große frage und den großen
streit um die sperrstunde
denn in vielen städten mit hohen
infektionszahlen gelten die erste wird
so gegen 23 uhr dann quasi der
bürgersteige hochgeklappt über die gäste
auf die straße gejagt in frankfurt ist
es so in berlin in bremen auch in nrw
soll es landesweit gelten
wir haben da marten kleinen überblick
gemacht nichts ist wie es mal war
im nachtleben deutscher großstädte
sperrstunde ab 23 uhr etwa in berlin und
frankfurt in stuttgart und köln zum
beispiel gilt stattdessen ein
abendliches alkoholverbot
vielerorts ist alkohol auch an beliebten
plätzen verboten wo sonst draußen
getrunken wird
und tatsächlich in berlin waren es wohl
partygänger die das virus verbreitet
haben
in den meisten anderen hotspots sind
laut robert koch institut aber private
feiern
das hauptproblem wie ist das aus ihrer
sicht herr schmidt chanasit urologe ist
das tatsächlich ende maßnahme die da
helfen könnte infektionsgeschehen zu
unterdrücken indem man eben die leute
irgendwann nach hause schickt na ja das
ist ganz schwer das ist eben wirklich
ein balanceakt auf der einen seite
schädigt man dadurch natürlich bar
betreiber der restaurants die sich
konsequent an regeln gehalten haben die
vielleicht auch dafür gesorgt haben
entsprechende luftbilder einzubauen und
so weiter und so fort also auch hier
hätte ich mir ein sehr zielgerichtetes
vorgehen gewünschte ausschankverbot
finde ich durchaus zielgerichtet und
eben berechtigt weil sich natürlich
menschen draußen angesammelt haben aber
wenn in einem restaurant nach 23 uhr mit
einem entsprechenden hygiene konzept
wein ausgeschenkt wird und das
restaurant bis 1 oder 2 auf hat spricht
meines erachtens
auch gar nichts dagegen also nochmal
hier geht es wiederum um die konsequente
umsetzung bereits bestehende maßnahmen
was viel wichtiger gewesen wäre
nun muss man sagen vielleicht ist das in
bestimmten städten einfach nicht
durchsetzbar weil das personal dafür
fehlt um das umzusetzen aber das hätte
man denke ich auch schon vor monaten
wissen können dass das problematisch
wird und sich eben hier unterstützung
zum beispiel durch private
sicherheitsdienste und so weiter
durchaus auch zur verfügung stehen
können
das ist die frage ob kontrollierte
feiern tatsächlich viel besser ist also
wie stelle ich mir das am besten vor
sollte ich sagen gibt es gibt es
irgendeine virologische zahl wo sie
sagen können ab der und der größe einer
feier ist ein infektionsgeschehen nicht
mehr kontrollierbar oder nicht mehr
nachvollziehbar oder ist das auch wieder
jetzt so eine zahl die die politik sich
mehr oder weniger aus den fingern
gesaugt hat mit 25 begrenzungen 50
personen begrenzungen ich glaube geben
ist klar je kleiner die gruppe ist desto
findest du darüber tragen kommt desto
geringer ist sozusagen die fähigkeit
eines menschen dort eben hunderte
anzustecken
das ist ja ein leuchtend und je und
darum gibt es eben diese begrenzung und
letztendlich muss man das an der
kapazität der gesundheitsämter
festmachen ob da eben 50 oder zehn
adäquat sind meines erachtens in einer
sehr brenzligen situation wo die dynamik
sehr hoch es ist es durchaus
nachvollziehbar noch zielgerichtet dass
ihm auf 10 oder ihn noch weniger zu
begrenzen es muss aber eben auch
umgesetzt und kontrolliert werden und
das ist der entscheidende punkt insofern
ist hier die maßnahmen dass man zum
einen die bundeswehr für die feier fall
vor verfolgung zur hilfe nimmt oder
bundesgrenzschutz oder private
sicherheit zumindest finde ich durchaus
wichtig und wir sehen auch in hamburg
dass das geklappt hat dort wurde
kontrolliert und dort wurden die läden
restaurants bars die sich nicht an die
regeln gehalten haben wo micky maus in
der liste stand oder man keine abstand
eingehalten wurde keine masken die
wurden konsequent geschlossen und das
ist auch nachvollziehbar
es muss sich an die bestehenden regeln
und das in weniger gehalten werden und
dann kommt es auch nicht zu den
problemen die wir jetzt sehen
hier gibt es noch ein kommentar von
patrick auf facebook da meint er privat
partys kommen nur weil die bass früher
schließen gibt es dazu erkenntnisse was
besser ist in anführungszeichen
so eine kleine bar wo kontrolliert wird
wie viele menschen sind in dem raum wie
verhalten die sich oder ist eine
privatparty mit fünf leuten dann
vielleicht doch das geringere risiko
weil es eben eine gruppe ist die sich
kennt also mein ganz subjektive
wahrnehmung ist dass alles was und damit
unter kontrolle mit einem hygiene
konzept stand stattfindet besser ist als
wenn es in der illegalität oder privat
stattfindet insofern bin ich vollkommen
dagegen mit generellen verboten zu
arbeiten man muss einfach auch diesen
menschen ein angebot machen weil es
sonst in die illegalität geht und dann
eben gar nicht kontrolliert wird dann
haben wir viel größeres problem insofern
man muss auf der einen seite maßnahmen
konsequent durchsetzen aber auf der
anderen seite auch gleichzeitig dafür
sorgen dass es ein ventil gibt das
feiern stattfinden können aber eben
sicher dass keiner anderen gefährdet
werden und da können zum einen hygiene
konzepte und zum anderen eben auch teste
helfen man kann ja eine bestimmte
personengruppe frei testen die dazu
einen zeitraum eben feiern können das
ist denkbar und das hätte man in den
letzten monaten schon konsequente
entwickeln und umsetzen müssen nur dafür
braucht entschlossenheit und das fehlt
eben zum teil verbote sind für die
politik einfach aber die konsequenz ist
gerade in der hinsicht einer pandemie
die noch monate dauern wird das ist
irgendwann schwierig wird und sich
verbote emig jahre lang durchhalten
lassen
hier kommt jetzt auch ein kommentar da
geht in die entsprechende richtung von
monika dörner auf facebook will man denn
private feiern untersagen schreibt sie
die feierwilligen gehen zur sperrstunde
aus dem restaurant und weiter nach hause
um dort weiter zu feiern das bekommt man
doch endlich in den griff
ich habe ja auch noch ganz andere fragen
zu schulbesuchen ob man wenn man ein
kind schicken könnte mit einer risiko
erkrankung oder risiko die zu einer
risikogruppe gehört das können wir jetzt
hier heute nicht so beantworten wir
wollen uns wirklich auf diese etwas
umstrittenen maßnahmen fokussieren wir
haben jetzt schon gesprochen über das
beherbergungs verbot für menschen aus
risikogebieten das sind mittlerweile 13
millionen personen in deutschland jetzt
gerade über die sperrstunde beides hält
herr schmidt chanasit für nicht so
richtig sinnvoll
sprechen wir mal über die massen pflicht
die tragen wir jetzt mittlerweile schon
ziemlich lange in geschlossenen räumen
aber es gibt jetzt auch massen pflichten
auf öffentlichen plätzen auch wieder
einen großen städten
genannt frankfurt hamburg oder köln
überall da wo viele menschen unterwegs
sind sollen die menschen jetzt auch
masken tragen und auch da fassen wir das
mal ganz kurz zusammen warum solch eine
maske tragen ich erklären sie mir das
hier ist niemand weit und breit
ich habe meine abend fünf wieder
ausstrecken ich finds halt
verantwortungslos von anderen dafür halt
keine tragen können auch viele leute die
angehörige haben und sicherheit sorgen
machen
von daher im gewissen maße kann man es
akzeptieren aber man kann es auch
übertreiben also ich habe wie gesagt
eben mit schon die berger straße runter
gelaufen haben die maske aufgesetzt und
ich trage auch eine brille und habe sie
auch vernünftiger weisen räumlichkeiten
beim einkaufen so aber hier den weg
runter sehe ich eine öffentlichkeit
eigentlich nicht ein und jetzt bin ich
auf der straße unterwegs soll niemals
geahnt haben bin ich aber irgendwo
taschen weite wege kann ich sie abziehen
also das ist im verhältnis verstehe ich
nicht ja da gibt es jetzt auch genau den
passenden kommentar dazu auf facebook
wann wird die masken pflicht fallen
möchte arabella wissen ich glaube das
dauert noch ein bisschen aber die frage
herr schmidt chanasit ist ja macht das
draußen sind ich habe jetzt immer
gelernt draußen ist viel luft bewegung
ein virus aero sohl verteilt sich
schnell können die massen auf solchen
öffentlichen plätzen was helfen
hier müssen wir uns einfach noch mal
daran erinnern was wir mit den a ha
regeln eigentlich sagen wollen abstand
ist das allerwichtigste hygiene und dann
alltags masten in den situationen wo
abstand nicht möglich ist so ist die
regel so und dann ist ihm klar dass das
risiko draußen geringer ist als drinnen
was aerosole betrifft aber natürlich
können tröpfchen auch draußen fliegen
aber sie fliegen eben nicht fünf oder
sechs meter wenn man jetzt noch mal
spricht sondern eben wenn man kein
abstand hält dann hat man eine risiko
das heißt masken machen draußen sinn
wenn abstand nicht eingehalten werden
kann so wäre die biologische definition
und die sinnhaftigkeit erklärt und
insofern kann ich die bürgerinnen und
bürger sehr gut verstehen die sagen wenn
ich alleine die straße runter laufen
selbst wenn ich an jemanden vorbei laufe
eine sekunde lang das ist kein risiko
auch wenn er ihm nur zehn zentimeter an
mir vorbei läuft noch mal
man muss den abstand nicht einhalten
längere zeit frontal mit einem anderen
sprechen damit eine risiko entsteht
draußen so insofern schließt hier
wichtig dass die verhältnismäßigkeit
gewahrt wird dort wo masken sinn machen
müssen sie korrekt verwendet werden also
das ist eigentlich das heißt jetzt
konkret ich bin auf einer also in
hamburg weiß ich zum beispiel
jungfernstieg ist glaube ich einer der
der bereiche dort sind viele menschen
unterwegs die gehen einander vorbei die
bleiben nicht stehen die reden nicht
miteinander
was halten sie dann dort für
unbedenklich da müsste man aus ihren aus
ihren augen in ihrer sicht keine maske
tragen
richtig für mich jetzt nicht jemand
direkt anrufen oder ins gesicht liest
was normalerweise vor der panne auch
nicht passiert ist dann ist das kein
problem wenn ich an jemanden vorbei geht
wie gesagt sie brauchen ja auch eine
gewisse zeit und eine gewisse viren
dosis damit es zu einer infektion kommt
was leuchtet ja eben ein
also noch mal es ist wichtig dass die
masken dort eingesetzt werden wo es auch
sinn ergibt wo infektionen
wahrscheinlich sind wo abständen nicht
eingehalten werden was ist dann der
weihnachtsmann wird wäre das dann wieder
während weihnachtsmarkt dann tatsächlich
so ein szenario wo sie sagen würden okay
ist zwar draußen aber die menschen
bleiben stehen unterhalten sich an
glühwein buden bleiben länger an allen
ständen stehen da wäre das dann sinnvoll
naja es ist ein bisschen schwer wie
wollen sie den glühwein trinken mit der
maske oder die bratwurst essen also hier
denke ich kann man anders regulieren
indem man einfach die menschenmenge so
begrenzt dass dies nicht sich ständig
auf die pelle rücken
ich glaube da gibt es sehr sehr gute
lösung auch die veranstalter haben da
schon gute ideen aber noch mal die regel
ist doch ganz einfach und
nachvollziehbar dort die masken zu
tragen wo abstand nicht möglich ist das
hat sich in den letzten monaten nie
geändert und ich weiß nicht warum man
jetzt eben hier auch neuere maßnahme im
erfinden muss wo man auch gar nicht eben
wirklich sagen kann ja dass das hat sich
in der letzten zeit gezeigt dass er
massenhaft infektionen in den
fußgängerzonen aufgetreten sind oder
eben auf den bahnhöfen wo leute
nebeneinander gestanden haben wir wissen
doch wo die infektionen eben aufgetreten
sind massenhaft und da muss man
zielgerichtet eingehen und eben nicht
mit anderen massnahmen sage ich mal eine
zusätzliche belastung für bürgerinnen
und bürger schaffen die sich immer gut
an die regeln gehalten haben
also auch da nimmt der virologe den
rotstift und streicht diese regel
einfach durch genau wie die bergungs
verbote und die sperre
stunde auch mit einem fragezeichen
versehen wurden gehen wir mal zur
nächsten diskussion reiserückkehrer
da gab es am anfang nach den
sommerferien großen er dabei einigen
weil die gesagt das ist es total unfair
dass jetzt die menschen aus
risikogebieten zurückkommen und sich
einfach kostenlos testen lassen können
das wurde hart diskutiert und bislang
galt halt folgende regelungen die wir
uns mal kurz angucken wer aus einem
ausländischen risikogebiet zurück nach
deutschland kommt muss zwei wochen in
quarantäne
alternativ können urlauber einen
negativen test vorlegen nicht älter als
48 stunden so da habe ich mal kurz in
den kommentaren guckt aber noch nichts
gefunden wo ich jetzt denke daß es sich
gerade lohnt aber diese regelung die
bisherige gegolten hat die soll fallen
und zwar ist jetzt der plan dass sich
reise rückkehrer aus risikogebieten
nicht mehr kostenlos testen lassen
können an flughäfen sondern erst mal
fünf tage in quarantäne gehen müssen um
dann einen test zu machen und wenn die
negativ ist werden sie aus der
quarantäne entlassen
das klingt jetzt für mich als laien erst
mal sinnvoll weil man kann sich ja auch
im flugzeug oder in der bahn anstecken
dann muss man erstmal nach hause gehen
muss gucken ob das virus ausbreitet dann
macht man tests und dann kann man sehen
ob man wieder auf die menschheit
losgelassen werden kann also ist das
virologisch eine sinnvolle maßnahme herr
schmidt chanasit
ja sie haben das sehr gut beschrieben
also diese möglichkeit gibt es aber wir
müssen da eben noch mal sehr ins detail
gehen um diese ganzen einzelnen punkte
dieser maßnahme wirklich zu erläutern
glaube ich und was eben weiß ich auch
kritisch sehe
zum einen finde ich gut dass wenn man
natürlich ein risikogebiet fährt diesen
test dann auch eben bezahlen muss ich
halte es schwierig pauschal alle
menschen fünf tage in quarantäne zu
schicken sie müssen sich ja vorstellen
wie er soll zu den leuten nach hause
gehen um dann dort nach fünf tagen den
test eben abzunehmen also das stellt uns
auch schon wieder vor die frage ist das
realistischen auf der anderen seite muss
man hier natürlich auch die frage
stellen wie viel mehr infektionen werden
denn dadurch erkannt sind das zehn
prozent mehr und ist es dass uns
wirklich wäre weil da steht ja extrem
viel auf dem spiel letztendlich sind
diese fünf tage quarantäne kommen auch
wiederum ein reiseverbot
reisen sind praktisch nicht durchführbar
ohne entsprechende ausnahmeregelungen
gerade auch geschäftsreisen also
insofern denke ich wäre es hier sinnvoll
gewesen auf dem bestehenden modell
aufzubauen zu sagen ja wir absichtlich
in risikogebiete fährt muss auch dann
eben diesen test der verpflichtete samen
flughafen selber bezahlen
aber auch hier nochmal reise ist eben
nicht gleich reise und das alles über
einen kamm zu scheren ist sehr schwer
derjenige der eben in mallorca war und
nur zwei tage zwei wochen am strand
gelegen hat und im ferienhaus hat
natürlich kein größeres risiko als der
der in berlin jeder jeden tag in die
wahl gegangen ist oder in die disco also
das muss man nochmal unterscheiden das
ist das einmaleins der reisemedizin der
reise stil das ganz entscheidend und
nicht unbedingt ruhig war
aber das problem ist da ja die politik
kann das sehr schwer kontrollieren und
die versucht natürlich irgendwie der
infektion logischen lage herr zu werden
indem sie solche regeln macht aber ich
kann natürlich auch einfach sagen klar
ich war auf mallorca war nicht feiern
habe da jeden tag am strand gelegen
hatte fiel abstand deswegen brauche ich
keinen test da ist die politik doch auch
wir sind hilflos oder sie versucht sich
ja doch jetzt irgendwelche
konstruktionen zu basteln um nicht den
vorwurf zu bekommen sie würden gar
nichts tun das kann ich nachvollziehen
aber nochmal ich denke prävention ist
ganz wichtig aufklärung ist ganz wichtig
wir müssen auch die mitbürgerinnen und
mitbürger die nicht deutsch sprechen
entsprechend aufklären die ihre familien
besucht haben das war auch ein
hauptgrund eben für infektionen die nach
deutschland eingebracht wurden also
zielgruppenspezifisch testen prävention
aufklärung ist ganz ganz wichtig als als
alles über einen kamm zu scheren und
eben auch einen massiven schaden
letztendlich zu verursachen und auch uns
die ärzte die labor ärzte für große
probleme zu stellen die gesundheitsämter
bei der durchsetzung dieser fünf tage
quarantäne
bei der test abnahme zu hause wer soll
das alles machen
also ich glaube hier geht es immer auch
um eine realistische lösung nun vor
allen dingen muss sie verhältnismäßig
seien ja und das sehe ich eben bei
dieser fünf tage regelung nicht hier
wären sicherlich mehr infektionen
dadurch detektieren aber den preis den
wir zahlen müssen sowohl bei den testen
als auch beim personalaufwand ist das
verhältnismäßig ich denke nein
dann gucken wir mal auf eine andere
frage der verhältnismäßigkeit nämlich
die dissen
fiktion von oberflächen hier bei uns im
zdf wurde sehr großzügig
desinfektionsspray verteilt jeder von
uns versucht die ganze zeit seine
oberfläche zu reinigen sein schreibtisch
sauber zu halten und jetzt gibt es auf
einmal die diskussion ist das überhaupt
sinnvoll ich zitiere jetzt mal kurz
damit der tafel vorbereitet klaus
reinhardt den präsidenten der
bundesärztekammer der hat am freitag
folgendes gesagt
sie findet ausschließlich über den
luftweg stadt und nicht über
schmierinfektionen also über die
verunreinigung von flächen insofern ist
die desinfektion von oberflächen die wir
derzeit noch sehr intensiv betreiben
unsinnig und obsolet
am anfang gab es heute die meldung auf
einmal australische wissenschaftler
hätten festgestellt dass das corona
virus bis zu 28 tage auf glatten
oberflächen überleben könne also wieder
zwei wissenschaftler oder zwei erste
zwei bis drei meinungen wie würden sie
diese erkenntnisse und die
einschätzungen der ärztekammer bewährten
herr schmidt chanasit
genauso wie die ärztekammer das ihn
bewertet hat also absolute der chor sind
ja laborexperimente und das geht ja auch
immer um die infektions dose ist also
nicht auf ein virus überlebt sondern ob
das virus was überlebt hat auch
ausreichend ist um infektionen menschen
hervorzurufen
und nach all dem was wir wissen wie die
übertragungswege sind die die infektion
stattfinden spielen schmierinfektionen
eine untergeordnete rolle ich würde
jetzt nicht komplett natürlich
aufschließen das ist auch mal eine
schmierinfektion geben kann ein sehr
anschauliches beispiel zb ich huste
direkt eben auf ein türgriff und
unmittelbar danach fest ein anderer
passant diesen schritt an und wischt
sich dann mit der hand durchs gesicht
also da kann man natürlich jetzt erst
mal keine infektion ausschließen aber
das ist ja ein vollkommen
unwahrscheinlich essverhalten und
insofern spiegeln auch die
infektionswege genau das wieder
schmierinfektionen sind sehr sehr selten
wenn sie überhaupt stattfinden und ein
kollege hat auch mal gesagt lieber ein
graben gehirn als 100 liter studium und
ich glaube das gibt es sehr sehr gut
wider
also ich fast damals zusammen was sie
uns bis jetzt gesagt haben die
beherbergungs verbote finden sie relativ
fragwürdig weil das infektionsgeschehen
in ihren augen nicht wirklich eingedämmt
werden kann die sperrstunden ähnliche
ähnliches urteil
dann haben wir geredet über die maßen
pflicht an öffentlichen plätzen auch da
haben sie ein fragezeichen hinter
gemacht dann gab es noch hier muss man
kurz gucken reiserückkehrer die
diskussion darum da würden sie auch an
der bestehenden regelung festhalten und
oberflächen würden sie nicht wie
wahnsinnig desinfizieren sondern eher
auf die artikeln setzen abstand
handhygiene und die alltags maß getragen
ich sehe auch in den kommentaren hier
viel ärger über die bestehenden
regelungen hier zum beispiel alexandra
michaela die schreibt wenn ich eine
ferienwohnung vermietet und weil es eine
abgeschlossene wohnt partei ist habe ich
abgesehen von der schlüsselübergabe
keinen kontakt zu den selbstversorgern
da stehe ich mit der situation dass da
wieder depp weil mir das auch noch
wegbricht denn sie ist sängerin schreibt
sie kann also derzeit nicht auftreten
und der betrieb in dem jemand angestellt
war hat auch noch seine pforten durch
corona geschlossen also dass tatsächlich
steht jetzt manche leute für richtig
große probleme ich weiß dass auch von
der reise vermietung reiseagentur wo ich
es gerade an der nordsee war die musste
alle kontakte anrufen die aus
risikogebieten kommt und fragen wollen
sie wirklich kommen das hat einen
ziemlich großen arbeitsaufwand gemacht
so schmidt chanasit ich habe ja noch ein
paar fragen die sind allgemein nicht zu
den maßnahmen haben wir noch mal ein
paar minuten zeit für ja gar nicht
möchte auch noch mal sagen das was die
anruferinnen oder so zu sagen was online
mitgeteilt wurde kam das absolut
nachvollziehen und ich finde das ganz
ganz wichtig dass uns dieser
zusammenhalt in der gesellschaft haben
eben nicht verloren geht und wir dürfen
das durch diese maßnahmen zusätzliche
maßnahmen eben nicht aufs spiel setzen
die zu unverständnis in der bevölkerung
führen das muss immer darauf geachtet
werden dass zielgerichtet
verhältnismäßig ist und dass wir das gut
erklären das ist glaube ich eine ganz
wichtige grundlage die insbesondere die
politik auch beherzigen sollte die
diskutiert ja auch gerade munter da kann
ich gerade nochmal nachschieben dass die
ministerpräsidentin von rheinland pfalz
malu dreyer heute abend gesagt hat dass
sie diese beherbergungs regeln erst mal
nicht umsetzen wird in ihrem bundesland
weil die diskussion bundesweit jetzt
gerade so im gange ist und sie erst mal
abwarten möchte so herr schmidt chanasit
ich hab so ein paar fragen einmal eine
frage die schon sehr lange diskutiert
wird zum pcr-test da wird nämlich die
frage stellt warum der nicht unter die
lupe genommen wird
alles steht und fällt mit dem test eines
virologen wird hier kommentiert der 2009
schon mal daneben lag und der 2014
seinen pcr-test selber in frage gestellt
hat dass da ist die rede von christian
drosten
also dieser pcr test gibt es immer
wieder fragen kritik daran ist er
überhaupt tauglich und kann dann mit
denen das virus überhaupt feststellen
was können sie dazu sagen ja und noch
mal eingangs es gibt nicht nur den einen
pcr-test in christian drosten entwickelt
hat es gibt hunderte die von großen ihr
agnostiker firmen auch entwickelt wurden
die weltweit seit jahrzehnten auch
eingesetzt werden also diese pcr tests
sind hoch verlässlich sie sind validiert
durch verschiedene ringversuche und der
test alleine ist ja auch immer noch
nicht sozusagen die aussage dann kommt
ja erst die fachärztliche tätigkeit wir
sehen dass testsignal oder dann muss das
sozusagen validiert werden es muss
interpretiert werden das heißt da drückt
nicht einem war dann vom knopf und sagt
positiv negativ sondern dann findet die
fachärztlichen tätigkeit stadt die
befund interpretationen gegebenenfalls
wird bei einem positiven befunden noch
eine zweite pca gemacht oder eine
sequenzierung unterschiedliche verfahren
also das muss den bürgerinnen und
bürgern klar sein dass das eine hoch
komplexe tätigkeit ist und das quasi das
nicht ein einziger pcr test ist in
christian drosten irgendwann mal
entwickelt hat ok dann gibt es immer
wieder auch fragenden kommentare hierzu
der intensiv belegung denn da wird auf
die zweite guckt sondern wird gesagt
okay wenn man auf sich hat die zahlen
anguckt bei der intensivbetten dann ist
die lage relativ entspannt ich habe
jetzt mal einmal hier den tages berichts
des intensiv registers aufgerufen
vielleicht schalten die kollegen mal
kurz auf meinen rechner
da sind jetzt die intensivmedizinischen
behandlungskapazitäten aufgeführt
aktuell belegt im lokal bereich also in
der nicht so hohen intensivbetreuung
13.000 160 betten und frei sind 1808 im
high care bereich also wirklich da wo es
um beatmung auch geht sind 6946 betten
belegt und frei sind 7528 und die ecc
moderierte das sind die die wirklich
beim atmen dann helfen quasi den
patienten richtig künstlich beatmen sind
615 353 beleg
herr schmidt chanasit finde ich mir
diese zahlen angucke würde ich als laie
sagen situation entspannt wir können uns
wieder hinlegen
naja also so ist das nur nicht entspannt
ist die situation nicht und jedem muss
klar sein dass es immer eine
momentaufnahme ist und das werden wir
natürlich zehntausende von infektionen
jeden tag hätten dass das irgendwann ihm
auch die wohl gerade population trifft
die eltern oder die patienten die
vorerkrankungen haben und dann können
sich diese zahlen ganz schnell ändern
insofern ist hier vorsicht angeraten wir
schützen die wohlrabe populationen
momentan sehr gute darum sind die zahlen
noch gering aber noch mal ist es eine
momentaufnahme
das kann sich ändern natürlich wenn die
zahlen eben sehr stark steigen wie
schnell müssen ihn dann steigen gibt es
da irgendwelche modellrechnungen wie
schnell in welchen zeitraum die steigen
müssten dass man sagen kann ok die
aktuell freien 7500 intensivbetten für
wirklich intensivmedizinische patienten
die auf beatmung brauchen diese
innerhalb von sechs tagen voll
nein also diese vorhersage sozusagen
diese modellierung ist sehr sehr schwer
das hängt ja auch immer damit zusammen
wodurch das infektionsgeschehen
getrieben wird durch welche
bevölkerungsgruppen durch weite welche
altersklassen und ob man eben gerade
diese wohlhabenden bereiche besonders
gut schützen kann also das ist eine ganz
komplexe modellierung insofern gibt es
diese zahlen leider nicht dass man sagen
kann heute haben wir zum beispiel 6000
test positive und dann werden wir in
zwei wochen entsprechend diese zahl auf
den intensivstationen sehen also so
einfach geht das leider nicht gut ich
schon noch mal kurz in die kommentare ob
ich da was finden was wir noch nicht
besprochen haben aber das sieht glaube
ich gerade nicht so aus eine frage habe
ich hier noch von ellen ehni sie live
auf facebook warum darf man sich 48
stunden in risikogebieten aufhalten und
einen test machen zu müssen können sie
die beantworten
ja das ist einfach sozusagen die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass man sich
infiziert nicht also die
wahrscheinlichkeit ist natürlich
wesentlich geringer hinzu kommt auch
noch mal die inkubationszeit von zwei
tagen die daneben da auftreten kann
das ist einfach so ein es muss ja
praktikabel sein dass man eben auch
irgendwo hin reisen kann ist es ein
erster schritt eben auch in die richtung
um geschäftsreisen möglich zu machen
es gibt noch eine frage die finde ich so
interessant
die möchte ich noch mal stellen ich
verstehe sie nämlich nicht vielleicht
verstehen sie hendrik meyer fragt auf
facebook ich soll sie fragen ob sie
absolut sicher bestätigen können dass
das corona virus anhand der kochshow
postulaten nachgewiesen wurde so hinter
kochshow postulate muss ich ein
fragezeichen setzen können sie das kurz
erklären und die frage beantworten
genau es muss entsprechend isoliert
seien in reinkultur des wurde ist und
dann muss es letztendlich in einem
organismus wieder die ähnliche
erkrankung hervorrufen das kann man
naturgemäß natürlich nicht in den
menschen infizieren
aber eben ins tiermodell und da kann es
die erkrankung hervorrufen also die
kochshow postulate soweit sie ihm für
ein virus erfüllbar sind es wo der
ursprung ich natürlich für ein bakterium
entwickelt sind erfüllt okay dann haben
wir die frage auch beantwortet dann gibt
es noch die frage hier petra schäfer die
anzahl der intensivbetten mag noch
reichen aber das personal dafür fehlt
doch da kann ich zu sagen dass zumindest
was diese dieses tief die intensivbetten
register angeht dass zumindest nach
ihren eigenen kriterien da auch das
personal dafür da sein muss ob das der
fall ist das kann natürlich niemand
überprüfen oder ob ein krankenhaus da
einfach was meldet
was vielleicht nicht der fall ist oder
haben sie da andere informationen nein
also ich habe da keine anderen
informationen aber das ist schon ein
wunder punkt ich glaube das darf man
auch durchaus nach vorne stellen dass
hier nach wie vor ein unheimlicher
bedarf besteht das lässt sich nicht von
heute auf morgen ändern aber ich glaube
langfristig muss ja wirklich viel getan
wenn dazu diesen pflegenotstand und
gerade eben die spezialisierten
pflegekräfte dass wir da einfach mehr
auch ausbilden oder mehr ins land wo hin
dass es ganz wichtig so jetzt gibt es
hier noch mal lustig sind und herrschen
mich an als it bezug nehmend nochmal auf
die frage ob das virus isoliert wurde
und tatsächlich nach dem kochen
postulaten heute abend was gelernt
nachgewiesen werden konnte schreibt
natürlich schwarz mit sehr vielen roten
ausrufezeichen
es wurden isoliert also das virus wurden
isoliert ist das eine richtige eine
falsche aussage das ist eine falsche
aussage ich habe sogar selbst isoliert
es ist nun mal so dass sie viren quasi
nicht ohne zellen isolieren die brauchen
ja erzählen um sich zu vermehren aber
sie können es dann aus dem tell kultur
überstand natürlich in reinform
darstellen wenn sie diesen zellkultur
überstand ohne zellen quasi in ein
hamster spritzen
ein frettchen erkranken diese tiere
insofern soweit es ihm möglich ist in
dieser postulate auch erfüllt und das
haben sie gemacht einen hamster
infiziert na ja das sind eben die
gängigen modelle die sind ja notwendig
um entsprechende impfstoffe zum beispiel
zu entwickeln oder auch ein um
entsprechende therapeutische zu
überprüfen
das sind eben natürlich gängige methoden
die verwendet werden um menschenleben zu
retten
so jetzt bin ich gespannt was auch für
den kommentaren kommt nicht guckt lieber
nicht nach und würde sagen vielen dank
für ihre zeit heute abend herr schmidt
chanasit vielen dank für eure fragen die
tatsächlich auch teilweise sehr
dezidiert waren wir versuchen sie
natürlich immer zu beantworten bedanken
uns bei den freundlichen und sachlichen
kommentatoren fordern die anderen wie
immer auf sich daraus nicht einmal
zusammenzureißen wir sind aber wieder da
mit dem nächsten live stream ganz bald
bis dahin sehr ich vielen dank fürs zu
gucken und tschüss